en este vídeo quiero hablarles acerca de
sub espacios y la multiplicación de una
matriz por un vector pero antes me
gustaría dar un resumen de que era un
sub espacio y qué propiedades habíamos
visto en un sub espacio así que aquí me
voy a tomar un sub espacio que hace
algunos vídeos habíamos hablado de ellos
y le voy a poner este sub espacio ese y
bueno ese era un sub espacio si cumplía
lo siguiente en primer lugar el vector 0
existía en ese esta es mi primera
condición que tiene que cumplir un sub
espacio la segunda de cielo siguiente si
tenemos los vectores b1 y b2 existentes
en el sub espacio entonces la suma de b1
b2 tiene que existir también en el sub
espacio si tenemos los vectores aquí en
su espacio la suma también tiene que
estar en este sub espacio esta es la
segunda propiedad que le pedíamos a un
sub espacio y la tercera era que era
cerrado bajo la multiplicación que
quiere decir eso que si nosotros tomamos
una constante los reales una constante
cm y después tomamos un vector que
existiera aquí en el sub espacio
entonces la multiplicación de este
escalar por mi vector de 1 tenía que
existir en el sub espacio esto quiere
decir que ese está cerrado bajo la
multiplicación así que si tenemos un
espacio se tiene que cumplir que el 0
existe en su espacio que si tenemos dos
vectores la suma existe en el sub
espacio y que una constante multiplicada
por un vector del sub espacio me dé un
vector que también existe aquí en el sub
espacio ahora vamos a pensar en lo que
habíamos hablado en el vídeo pasado
acerca de la multiplicación de una
matriz por un vector me voy a tomar una
matriz a que sea de m por n la dimensión
de asm por n y bueno yo es lo que quiero
aplicarme es la ecuación homogénea que
justo en este momento te voy a definir
si yo tengo esta matriz multiplicada por
un vector y esto igualado al vector cero
entonces estamos hablando de que tenemos
una ecuación homogénea tenemos una
ecuación homogénea porque tenemos
igualada cero
ahora bien te quiero preguntar lo
siguiente todos estos vectores que
cumplen esta ecuación homogénea
forman un sub espacio es decir si me
tomo a todo el universo a todo el
conjunto de vectores x que cumplan esta
propiedad de la ecuación homogénea será
que ellos forman un sub espacio válido a
ver intentemos escribir el conjunto me
queda el conjunto de las equis que
existen en rn y ojo mis vectores viven
en rn porque mi matriz es de m por n y
la única forma de definir esta
multiplicación es que x tenga n
componentes recuerdas si la matriz era
de m por n entonces el vector tenía que
ser de n x 1 y bueno yo lo que le estoy
pidiendo a este vector es que cumpla que
la matriz a multiplicada por este vector
x sea igual a 0
este es el conjunto de todo el universo
de vectores que cumplan esta propiedad
mi pregunta en este caso es este
conjunto un sub espacio pues vamos a ver
tenemos que cumplir estas tres
propiedades la primera que el cero
existe en ese así que vamos a intentar
ver si 0 existe
en este sub espacio voy a tomar a la
matriz a y le voy a multiplicar por el
vector 0 será que esto me cumple que es
igual al vector 0 vamos a ver si yo
tengo aquí a la matriz a que tiene como
entradas a 11 a 12 hasta 1 ene y para
abajo a 11 a 21 hasta a m 1 y hasta acá
tenemos a la entrada a mn ya que tenemos
todas estas entradas y ahora lo
multiplicó por el vector 0 el vector 0
si te das cuenta es aquel vector que
está en rn pero que todas sus
componentes son 0 así que tenemos n 012
y hasta llegar a línea vocero todas las
componentes de este vector son 0 y bueno
pues ha llegado la hora de recordar cómo
definimos la multiplicación de una
matriz por un vector lo primero que
quiero que recuerdes es que nuestro
resultado era un vector y en cada una de
sus componentes nos quedaba lo siguiente
a 1 1 x 0 + a 1 2 x 0 + así hasta llegar
a más 1 n por 0 eso en nuestra primer
componente así que si tenemos todo x 0
me quedan 0 en la primera componente en
las
el componente sería a 2 1 x 0 + a 2 2 x
0 + a 2 3 x 0 + así hasta llegar aa 12 n
x 0 pues también me va a dar 0 y en el
siguiente también me va a dar 0 y así si
nos seguimos fila por fila multiplicando
por este vector 0 pues nos va a dar 0 0
0 0 recuerda que una de las formas de
ver la multiplicación de una matriz por
un vector era tomar el producto punto de
cada uno de los vectores filas de la
matriz a punto nuestro vector x que en
este caso es el vector 0 y entonces si
te das cuenta nuestro resultado nuestro
vector resultante va a ser cero cero
cero cero cero cero o sea el vector cero
y por lo tanto acabamos de ver que el
vector cero si cumple y si se cumple
esta ecuación homogénea nuestro vector
cero esto quiere decir que el cero
existe en este conjunto que estamos
construyendo en el conjunto de todos los
vectores que existen en rn tales que
cumplen la ecuación homogénea entonces
el cero existe y ahora vamos a probar la
siguiente propiedad que por cierto le
voy a poner el nombre de n n va a ser el
conjunto de todos estos vectores
entonces ya tenemos que el cero existe
en n
ahora vamos a tomarnos dos vectores aquí
en n vamos a tomar los dos vectores que
cumplan esta ecuación homogénea será
acaso que la suma de estos dos vectores
exista también en n es decir cumple la
ecuación homogénea entonces b1 b2
existen en n y bueno por definición si
b1 y b2 existen n n quiere decir que a
por b 1 es igual a 0 y que a por b 2 es
igual a cero es decir cumplen la
ecuación homogénea vamos a escribirlo
aquí a por b 1 es igual a 0 ya por b 2
es igual a 0 y estos por construcciones
precisamente de este de este conjunto n
habíamos dicho que todos los vectores
que vivían en este conjunto n en
especial de 192 cumplen la ecuación
homogénea
entonces ya tengo que a por ver uno es
igual a cero por b 2 es igual a 0
qué va a pasar si aumentamos la matriz
ya multiplicó por la suma de estos dos
vectores la matriz a x b1 b2 y bueno
creo que no he visto en ningún vídeo que
cuando yo multiplico a una matriz por
una suma de vectores esto cumple la
propiedad distributiva sin embargo
es muy fácil que lo veas sería cuestión
de que tú lo trabajaras un poco y que tú
solito demostrar es que la
multiplicación de una matriz por una
suma de vectores cumple la distributiva
y that o sino en algún vídeo pronto haré
estas demostraciones pequeñas que son
bastante interesantes y que en este
momento me va a servir bastante porque
tengo que a por ver uno más b 2 que es
exactamente lo mismo que la matriz a por
b 1 más la matriz a por b 2 pero a por
de 1 es el vector 0 ya por b 2 es el
vector 0 y el vector 0 más el vector 0
nos da el vector 0 esto quiere decir que
cumplimos la segunda propiedad de un
súper espacio me tomé dos vectores aquí
nn y estoy descubriendo que si yo me
tomo la suma de estos dos vectores y
trabajo un poco con ellos entonces llegó
a que vea uno más de dos también existen
en n porque cumplen la ecuación
homogénea y perfecto entonces ya tengo
un punto más para el sub espacio lo voy
a poner aquí b1 b2 también existe en n
esta es mi conclusión y por lo tanto ya
tengo mi segunda propiedad en el segundo
punto de un sub espacio será que cumple
la tercera que está sí precisamente la
tercera es la que no cumple así que me
voy a tomar
en n b 1 están n y como están en el
cumple que a por b 1 es igual al vector
0 y ahora me voy a tomar una constante
por b 1 será queda constante por b 1
también existe en este conjunto n pues
vamos a ver quién es la matriz a que
multiplica a la constante por b 1 pues
vamos a calcular esto si esto es igual a
0 entonces cumple la ecuación homogénea
y entonces ya acabamos de demostrar que
si es un sub espacio sin embargo otra
propiedad que no demostrado pero que
realmente es muy sencilla de mostrar y
creo que en algún vídeo voy a demostrar
estas cositas que son muy sencillas sin
embargo sería muy bueno que tú
trabajaras en ellas es que si yo tengo
una constante multiplicado a un vector y
después tengo una matriz multiplicando a
esto entonces la constante puede salir
es decir puede quedar en un principio es
decir me va a quedar esto igual a la
constante por la matriz a que a su vez
multiplica al vector
y ojo la constante es un número mientras
que la matriz y el vector no lo son pero
yo lo que sé es que a por b es igual a
cero recuerda que no
vector b 1 por construcción existía en n
este es el vector m 1 existía en n y por
lo tanto cumple la ecuación homogénea
por lo tanto esto de aquí es el vector 0
y una constante multiplicando el vector
0 pues es una constante que multiplica 0
0 0 0 0 y eso es el vector 0 también y
ya está perfecto acabo de demostrar
también esta propiedad la tercera
propiedad para que fuera un sub espacio
si tengo a un vector en n entonces la
constante por el mismo vector también
existen n cumple la ecuación homogénea y
por lo tanto acabamos de llegar a que
este conjunto n de todo el universo de
vectores que cumplen la ecuación
homogénea es un sub espacio perfecto es
decir acabamos de ver que el 0 el vector
0 existen en el que el conjunto
encerrado bajo la suma y además es
cerrado bajo la multiplicación ya este
conjunto n se le conoce como el espacio
nulo de a muy importante este conjunto n
se le conoce como el espacio no lograda
que no puede ser que naranja n es igual
al espacio nulo
matriz es decir que si en uno de los
siguientes vídeos yo te pregunto cuál es
el espacio nulo de una matriz am y te
doy una matriz arbitraria a entonces si
yo te digo encuentran el espacio no lo
dejan
voy a pensar en el conjunto de todos los
vectores que existan en rn el universo
de todos estos vectores tales que
cumplan que a por cada uno de estos
vectores x sea igual al vector ser y voy
a hablar de esto en el siguiente vídeo